Every Thanksgiving, Americans eat close to 736 million pounds of turkey.
That’s the weight of almost a thousand 747s at takeoff.
So how does a turkey make it to your plate?
It all starts with an act of love … usually, artificial insemination.
As soon as a day later, you’ve got an egg that travels to a hatchery
that becomes a baby turkey, that’s shipped off to a barn, often in Minnesota.
If that weren’t hellish enough, after about 18 weeks the now mature turkey
gets sent to a processing plant.
Hint: Processing is kind of a euphemism.
The turkeys get unloaded in the dark … and is stunned through electrocution or gas.
Next, the throat slitting machine.
Then scalding, picking and more gross stuff.
Time for packaging – only the prettiest turkeys are packaged whole.
Then the turkey’s shipped to a grocery store.
Where you buy it, take it home and roast it.
At this point, we’d like to ask: white meat or dark?